[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos una vez más a
esta emisión de canadá en las americanas
café y el programa semanal que les
ofrecemos desde el servicio en español
de radio canadá internacional y en esta
ocasión estamos aquí
este ámbito porque no es nuestro estudio
habitual
pablo gómez barrios que tal pablo muy
bien gracias y luis laborda y como
ustedes verán no estamos en el estudio
de radio canadá internacional estamos
hablando en a mejorar no es nuestro
entorno natural estamos en otro espacio
un espacio muy saga lusa que está
ubicado en la calle ontario en pleno
centro de montreal y estamos aquí por un
evento en particular que es que en el
mes de febrero cada año aquí en canadá
se celebra como nosotros lo hemos
denominado en español el mes de la
historia de la negritud
para decir aquel mes que se dedica a
recuperar resaltar a homenajear el rol
de la gente de color negro que vive aquí
en canadá o que ha vivido aquí en canadá
se recuerda también a las generaciones
precedentes que son una parte integrante
de esta comunidad y que han hecho un
aporte y siguen haciendo un aporte
cultural artístico político en diversos
ámbitos como es natural vamos a tener
invitados estamos con invitados pero
antes le queríamos dar una pequeña
introducción al tema como ustedes saben
en nuestro sitio en internet encuentran
una página que está dedicada al mes de
la historia de la negritud y que está
disponible todo el año en una dirección
internet que es www rc y net punto sea
barra e s de español barra
y profundidad ahí encuentran todo el año
el material disponible el material que
producimos desde hace años para el mes
de la historia de la negritud en la
sección en español y en el mes de
febrero en particular hay una sección
que está destacada en la primera página
de nuestro sitio internet en la que
ustedes pueden acceder a todo el
contenido entrevistas reportajes
material fotográfico etcétera en canadá
según las cifras oficiales hay casi un
millón doscientas mil personas de color
negro
repartidas en todo el territorio las
provincias que tienen una mayor
incidencia de población negra son
ontario luego le sigue québec alberta
columbia británica
manitoba y nueva escocia pero también
hay en el resto del territorio gente de
color negro esas cifras son oficiales y
corresponden al censo de población del
año 2016 y pablo decíamos que tenemos
invitados vamos a tener más invitados
invitados creo que el invitado masculino
está llegando en este momento a mi
derecha está ana espinoza que es
bailarina y docente y es originaria de
cuba de la ciudad de la habana la
capital de cuba pero vives aquí
anna de 6 a 10 años
bueno también contamos con la presencia
de mariana valdez que es promotora de
diversas actividades e iniciativas
también en el ámbito artístico yo la he
bautizado como militante social aunque
ella no estaba muy de acuerdo pero ya le
quedó el otro también y se está sumando
en pocos instantes más a nuestra mesa
gabriel bazán que es el vicepresidente
de la liga de los negros de quebec con
él también vamos a dialogar
este año el motivo de la celebración el
lema de la celebración de la historia de
la negritud aquí en canadá es el de
voces de emancipación
y la pregunta inicial podría ser
entonces para comenzar con nuestro
nuestro diálogo con nuestra conversación
con esta mesa de debates sobre la
negritud que hemos establecido hoy es
es necesario emanciparse todavía de algo
aquí en canadá para la gente que
pertenece a la comunidad negra de este
país tú qué dices hada
pero yo no lo veo así
yo desde que llegué en el 2009 hace ya
10 años yo me he sentido con las puertas
abiertas aquí en este país con las
puertas abiertas de todas las
comunidades la comunidad afro la
comunidad latina la comunidad qué becas
en general me sentía así y hasta el
momento he tenido solo buenas
experiencias aquí con todas las
comunidades trabajé en estudio visto un
tiempo es un lugar donde recibimos mucha
gente aquí del ámbito cultural
de diversas artes
con todas mis relaciones muy bien
con todas me sentía a gusto
hasta el momento siempre ha sido así
entonces no me emancipó y ahora tú dices
que sé que las puertas se abrieron desde
un primer momento que puerta se abrieron
las laborales del estudio
las laborales la de la integración muy
importante estuve desde el primer
momento en un curso de francés para
poder aprender y comunicarme como soy
profesora también pues es una necesidad
básica que tenía
desde que aprendí el francés y empecé a
hablar con la gente a dar mis clases
pues las puertas laborales se fueron
abriendo también encontré este trabajo
en el estudio donde además doy mis
clases diferentes contratos por aquí y
por allá y siempre sin ningún problema
perfecto muy bien y pablo a tu izquierda
inmediata está mariana
la primera persona de la línea
ecuatorial con quien tengo el gusto de
conversar y en español además o sea que
me parece fantástico cuánto tiempo lleva
ya viviendo acá marianas
casi 10 años y llegaste 9 desde el 2009
y llegaste sin qué temporada y qué
estaciones que mes del año
en octubre agua en nuestro sector ya
estábamos en el fin del otoño estaba
comenzando ni siquiera te he de lo que
el frío de lo que era el frío todavía
pero habías tenido cuando estabas allá
en guinea ecuatorial como se llama de la
ciudad de dónde vienes málaga malabo
cuando estabas en malabo alguna vez te
imaginaste que podías estar en un lugar
como éste aquí en canadá con tanta nieve
y tanto frío bueno yo ya lo había visto
en la tele no
de verdad es totalmente distinta
pero
el choque cultural no ha sido tanto la
nieve yo creo que el choque cultural es
el hecho de que estén varias
nacionalidades de tantos países
africanos que vienen aquí y que no se
conocen ya que estamos hablando del mes
de la negritud y también junto a lo que
dijiste sobre la emancipación yo creo
que si existe un mes de la negritud es
porque aún hay un trabajo que hacer
en el sentido de que si es que realmente
la gente está emancipada la gente tiene
tanta inclinación la gente se siente
como si canadá es el país de ellos no
necesitamos tener un mes de la negritud
donde se tiene que recordar a la gente
que esta es nuestra historia
allí es donde venimos eso es como no
tendría que existir este tipo de
iniciativa y si existe es porque hay un
trabajo
el sistema no está haciendo a lo mejor
los que vienen y se integran están
intentando hacer pero aún vamos a ver
entonces sobre el trabajo que queda
pendiente para hacer según tu opinión
mariana pero quería antes de proseguir
introducir a nuestro tercero invitado
que está allí inmediatamente a la
derecha de pago que es el señor gabriel
bazar que es el vicepresidente lo hemos
producido así en español no sé si en la
dirección correcta de la liga de los
negros de quebec bien es bien bienvenido
cómo está usted bastante bien cuál sería
el principal desafío que enfrenta la
liga de la comunidad negra aquí en
quebec en este momento
nuestra preocupación
es de luchar contra
la discriminación
sobre todas las las formas que se
presentan hay discriminación actualmente
hacia la comunidad negra
sí claro que sí
desde el año 67
pero
no sabía nada
antes de esta semana esta semana yo
tengo la oportunidad de aprender que hay
empresas que no entregan inmigrantes
tiene que dar mucho dinero
para que emplean negros inmigrantes eso
ha ocurrido aquí en montreal si usted es
de origen haitiano a los 22 años de
venta muchas cosas que vamos a hablar
entonces de cuáles son las diferencias
que usted encontró entre una sociedad y
la otra en su viaje hacia américa del
norte pero vamos a volver entonces a
anna que espinoza con esta actividad
actual han aquí
y profesora de danza danza oriental y
porque profesora de danza oriental
siendo una nativa cubana
pregunta te pica ya pues
viviendo en mi país en la habana en cuba
15 siempre me interesó como un poco esta
parte de la cultura árabe tenía un grupo
de amigas que también estaban
interesadas en lo mismo y estábamos como
cansadas
y la salsa
los bailes exactamente y desde que
nacemos como nacemos con eso entonces
queríamos explorar otras cosas
en cuba pues esta danza todavía no se
conoce mucho bueno en esa época ahora se
conoce más y por eso que hicimos y
decidimos pues explorar más y cómo
invertir de nuestro tiempo para
profundizar y aprender de estado y por
eso empecé en el 2003 y no separados
micro adaptación en ese sentido entonces
ha sido fácil ha podido cristalizar tu
escuela de danza que funciona por lo
tibio bien más que bien al principio muy
difícil aquí muy difícil porque la
competencia es feroz hay muchas escuelas
de danza y como no hay un control sobre
eso también cualquier persona puede
aprender un poco y después hacer una
escuela y enseñar
desde ese punto de vista es difícil pero
ya después de 10 años pues ya se
funciona bastante no sé si me coanimador
pablo gómez barrios quiere hacerte
alguna pregunta por el momento acabo de
recibir un mensaje de nuestra colega
paloma que nos sugería que nos echáramos
un poquitito más para allá para que para
que el señor pase se integra más en la
mesa baja se puede ingresar en cuadro
estas son las vicisitudes de transmitir
desde un lugar que no es el habitual y
que hay que acomodarse a último momento
pero la cosa va a salir adelante de
todas maneras y es así es entonces bueno
con respecto si me quedé intrigado con
aquello de la danza oriental
pero
hay alguna tradición o hay algo en cuba
si que te haya impulsado a seguir danza
oriental pues en cuba hubo una
emigración árabe sobre todo del líbano
muy fuerte y de hecho mi mejor amiga en
cuba es sí
herencia libanesa e incluso hay una
unión árabe de cuba y yo yo era
estudiante de historia en la universidad
en este tiempo entonces históricamente
también me interesaba mucho todo lo que
es el medio oriente y desde ahí pues fue
otro gancho más pero pero la comunidad
sirio-libanesa o libanesa que estaba
instalada en cuba' traían consigo esas
tradiciones y se veía la danza oriental
y si se veía pero había que como
interesarse en eso no es una cosa que
sea difundida por el gobierno
y que vas a ver todos los días ahora se
ve más porque nosotros pongamos una
escuela ya que ya ha crecido mucho es
una compañía de danza y música que
hacemos también y ahora se conoce más
pero en el 2003 de 2002-2003
era muy específico era un lugar que es
la unión árabe de cuba donde se hacían
las actividades y uno tenía que
interesarse en ir al lugar o preguntar
sobre las actividades porque no es una
cosa que era tan difundido yo quería
preguntarle a mariana marín aval de cuál
esta actividad actual aquí mariana que
te estás ocupando en este mismo momento
en la actualidad
y social para un organismo en verdad y
este mi trabajo consiste en acompañar
familias
y niños a partir de siete años hasta los
diecisiete y lo que hacemos en verde es
favorecer la integración de estas
familias inmigrantes y organizar
programas de actividades y encontrar
modos de intervención para que esas
familias puedan sentirse realmente en su
hogar y cuál es el desafío principal que
esas familias enfrentan a la hora de
integrarse a la nueva sociedad
cuál es el problema más frecuente que tú
detectas dentro de tu actividad respecto
de esa clientela de esas familias que
son familias de diversos orígenes
el hecho de que muchos muchas familiares
no nos conocen el sistema educativo y la
mayoría de los niños es decir hay
latinos africanos están otras personas
de asia
asiáticos
los papás no pueden ayudar a esos niños
en los deberes
y esto pues es un problema porque luego
se habla de de cruzar
köhler se habla de que los niños no
pueden ir a clase no se integran y son
problemas que encontramos diez años
después o antes ese tubo hacía
referencia es la deserción escolar lo
que decimos en español deserción escolar
cuando los niños abandonan la educación
y es verdad que cuando uno emigra la
gente que no lo hay que no emigrados no
lo sabe pero cuando uno emigra hasta lo
cotidiano es un desafío porque hay que
aprenderlo prácticamente desde cero a mí
me pasó si queremos contar una pequeña
anécdota que pinta cuan tonto o
desconocedor puede ser una de las
cuestiones mínimas en un nuevo país es
que uno
un día cuando yo acababa de llegar a
canadá esperaba el autobús para ir a mis
cursos de francés y era un día en el
cual el autobús había cambiado de
recorrido yo no sabía que ese día el
autobús cambiaba de recorrido que pasaba
por otro lugar no lejano pero no era la
misma parada de autobús a la que asistía
cada día para montarme en él y pase creo
que una hora y media esperando que
autobús llegará y el autobús nunca
apareció así como uno desconoce una cosa
tan sencilla como es a enfrentar trabajo
estudios hacen un trámite de sanitario
recurrir a la ayuda de un médico
inscribirse en un curso etcétera puede
ser todo un desafío para un inmigrante
eso tú como interventora social lo sabes
que eso ocurre frecuentemente exacto y
el señor obama nos decía que él vivió en
eeuu antes de llegar a canadá cuál es la
diferencia principal que encontró entre
un país y otro desde el punto de vista
personal
en los eeuu
la vida
estaba
más demasiado rápida para mi
personalidad la extracción entre acá
primero como profesor de literatura a la
universidad el profesor de francés en
que grecia las universidades están la
nueva esposa y después entré aquí como
profesor y después del estudio el
derecho tenía la oportunidad de práctica
el derecho durante algunos años y
después
soy muy activo para los inmigrantes en
los casos de inmigración
este llama esta mañana tenía un caso de
mi nuestro
en los tribunales en el tribunal ya que
estuvo allí como en carácter de que de
mediador en el presente para defender y
defensor
perfectos en inmigración inmigración
sumada en inmigración 52 años señor base
a quién
no me gusta contar los años para pasar
diez años y el besar mi país
estoy aquí todavía pero yo llevo 43 años
viviendo acá así que 52 y lo que usted
me decía ahorita que concuerda un poco
con lo que dice mariana también es que
a su juicio todavía hay racismo acá
absolutamente la médula prueba es que el
frente de la misma oficina en final no
estaba con un abogado
el criminalista
había dos los miembros cuatro miembros
de la policía estaba conduciendo un
cable en w
el arte cercano estaba parado
la policía viene
qué hace usted a tapa
él explicó
dame las informaciones sobre usted
dos meses después a la medianoche
estábamos en la calle de salud en chubut
había dos miembros de la policía pero el
conocido está en tipo que el estudio
también para la policía el dice a esta
gente estaba siguiéndome el cabo de la
policía se derriba y sobre la calle se
abre pero siguen nosotros la primera
pregunta que hace usted en la vida
porque no está más en este vaso puesto
le tiene a este cargo
tú ves
en la calle señora un negro por ese a un
hombre que está haciendo vendiendo
drogas o proxenetismo o simplemente
trabajando o simplemente paseando o
haciendo cualquier actividad que hace
cualquier otra persona hicieron un
después
tu placas de matriculación no está
registrada no podría darles de una
contravención pero puede
es la realidad de cada día y esto huele
mal y si a usted para comprender cuando
estaba en el tercero en el tres años en
mi curso a la universidad de derecho
en el segundo año había un negro después
ahora en el primer año estaba la esposa
de este hombre
había un profesor de la universidad
haitiano que me dice qué pasa qué pasa
porque hace años que están tratando de
entrar en la facultad de derecho como
estudiante
pero no expulsa
le conté su me contesta fue
la movilidad de los estudiantes mismos
si usted no estaba profesor acá usted
tenía más estudiantes que hicieron el
colegio teníamos estudiantes que mejor
tienen hicieron el segundo pero esta
gente estaba muy activo en la asociación
como militante algo así comprende este
hombre estaba el profesor no pudo entrar
esto quiere decir que tomaron uno cada
año para la forma
la educación hoy es distinta podemos
decir que es distinta al parecer porque
lo que gabriel base en señalaba al
principio cuando se sentó a la mesa fue
algo que ocurrió recientemente y me
permite encadenar con lo que decía con
lo que decía marianas cuando hablamos
del mes
de la negritud y por qué por qué tiene
que haber eso cuando en realidad pues si
no hubiera el racismo que parece haber
no se necesitaría el mes como tal
claro también es que no es tanto la
cuestión del racismo porque porque él
existe nazismo es el conocimiento de la
cultura del desconocimiento pero es
decir que si tú ejemplo tú me hablas
eres bailarina
tú haces esto si yo no entiendo que es
el ballet o si yo lo entiendo lo que lo
que es bailar o el tipo
yo me hicieron a la conversación contigo
porque yo no entiendo y por eso existe
justamente es para explicar a las
personas allí es de donde yo vengo así
es la cultura
así es como nosotros funcionamos también
tenemos personajes de raza negra que
también tienen capacidades que
estudiaron que son modelos que pueden
ser modelos para la sociedad que ve acá
y yo creo que existe un mes como este
para que un concepto como el racismo de
aquí a lo mejor a 50 o más de 50 años no
nos hable
[Música]
bueno seamos realistas y optimistas
tiempo conseguiremos en un poco antes si
hay que dar en febrero del año pasado el
primero del ministro de canadá
había hecho una declaración en febrero
diciendo que las cárceles de canadá
tienen demasiado detenidos de dos horas
y eso es una tentación y listo está en
misión el primer ministro ahora cuando
hablamos de integración sabemos que
siempre hay un trabajo de doble vía es
decir por un lado es quien quien llega a
quien tiene que hacer muchas veces el
mayor esfuerzo en mayor trabajo para
sumarse a la nueva sociedad pero también
hay un trabajo que tiene que hacer esa
sociedad para adoptar para integrar a
los recién llegados creen que aquí la
sociedad toma suficientemente en cuenta
a los inmigrantes en general y a las
personas de color negro en particular
como uno más de esa sociedad global
diversa de la que hablaba esta mañana
hace un rato que es la sociedad
quebequense en la que nosotros nos toca
más cerca pero canadiense en general
creen que ese trabajo está hecho en el
doble sentido o creen que la sociedad
debe hacer un esfuerzo mayor al que sea
hasta ahora tú qué piensas sana
primeramente está el curso este de
francis acción que yo tuve la suerte de
hacer yo creo que aún existe y que es un
curso para aprender francés pero también
para ayudar al inmigrante a integrarse
entonces eso yo lo veo muy válido la
parte del gobierno y yo creo que en un
momento hoy que iban a anularlo pero yo
creo que sigue y es como vital la lengua
difícil situación exactamente y además
los profesores como te te daban algunos
secretos de cómo integrarse bien a la
sociedad y en cuanto a la lengua
los secretos y los y en cuanto a la
lengua también como expresiones que se
que decimos aquí que que no las
enseñaron para eso mismo para poder
entender y estar más mejor integrados y
lo otro también que me pareció muy
válido cuando llegué fue desde el punto
de vista laboral hay un organismo que
ahora no recuerdo el nombre
y ayuda al inmigrante a prepararse para
una entrevista
estuve ligada a uno del gobierno
que incluso te dan como el derecho a un
monto que puede pagar al nuevo trabajo
dónde va a estar como la parte esta de
empezar y de cómo entrenarte en la parte
del entrenamiento que este organismo
también lo ofrece y te ayuda a preparar
tu cb entonces yo encontré estas cosas
muy bien la verdad que a diferencia de
otros amigos que tengo hay muchos
cubanos en el mundo ustedes deben estar
al tanto hay muchos cubanos por todo el
mundo porque la situación en juba
todavía es muy crítica y tengo otros
amigos que a diferencia mía pues no han
tenido la misma suerte han tenido que
como decimos en cuba' batear más duro la
pelota porque
turístico sí
porque en el país donde han ido a vivir
no ha sido igual han tenido que sufrir
más han tenido que otros países fuera de
la luz y fuera de canadá en canadá en
otro país en europa en eeuu
han tenido que
que pasar más trabajo a nivel de la
integración
mariana te tratábamos la pregunta desde
el punto de vista de la sociedad cuál es
el trabajo que falta hacer para
facilitar esa integración yo creo que
cada comunidad tiene una responsabilidad
yo voy a dar un ejemplo a la comunidad
africana cuando llegue a un africano y
decir que en áfrica y 54 países países
es decir que en 54 realidades distintas
la cultura la lengua todo es diferente
el africano como hace para integrarse no
hay un libro y un pequeño libro
no hay un manual de integración y de
hecho en verde no con una de las
organizaciones estamos trabajando en un
proyecto que se llama el foro de las
mujeres emprendedoras en la diversidad
el objetivo de este foro es poder
documentar las preocupaciones de las
mujeres de la diversidad y poderlo poner
en un manual que es será un manual de
integración para que las personas
inmigrantes de diversas razas de todo
tipo de país al llegar puedan tener un
manual donde están las referencias donde
están modelos de personas que tuvieron
un éxito
en una
en su trabajo o simplemente en su pasión
para que cuando tú vienes como
inmigrante puedes saber que ok yo me
gusta bailar pero cuáles son los modelos
cubanos o africanos o haitianos que
existen que también tuvieron
esta integración que a lo mejor no
sabían por dónde empezar y en este
manual tu puedes contactar esas personas
tu puedes saber cómo lo hicieron donde
fueron ellos a estudiar y donde existen
por ejemplo esas clases de francés
acción no todo el mundo es llegar y
abrir internet porque cuando vas a
internet no no no lo hay no sobre todo
en un país como éste que recibe mucha
gente de lugares en los que hay una gran
crisis económica donde hay guerra donde
hay violencia donde la formación
académica no se encuentra tan
desarrollada como en otros países no
todo el mundo tiene a su disposición las
herramientas podrá acceder a la
tecnología incluso a leer en muchos
casos entonces esa información se
convierte aún en más es difícil pablo te
cedo la palabra sí gracias gracias luis
y le quería preguntar a gabriel que
después o sea 52 años en toda una vida
como cómo se siente usted o sea gente
que se ha integrado a la sociedad que ve
que se siente que la sociedad que ve
quién se lo ha aceptado como como se
siento que me parece
personalmente estoy integrado
personalmente
yo tengo la aceptación de la sociedad
pero esto no me interesa es el interés
colectivo no es 210 mil no es 210
modelos que tienen éxito lo que queremos
es la igualdad para todos
no es asunto el éxito para 210 y en la
que fue gobernador general de canadá el
que fue diputado se trata de éxito
individual queremos igualdad para todos
y esa igualdad a su juicio no existe
existe y ya piensa que hay mucho mucho
trabajo que hacer mucho trabajo que
hacer mucho más
decimos los instantes que la lengua es
una de las herramientas básicas
centrales de esa integración social con
la nueva sociedad y hay una
característica muy particular en esta
mesa que es la de una representante de
un país africano en una gloria línea
ecuatorial exactamente que tiene como
lengua materna el español
y justamente es es el único país que
habla español pero imagínense 54 países
y que está uno se diría que este país
vive racismo que este país vive
discriminación que ese país vive todo lo
que se puede hablar aquí de un
inmigrante que viene a quebec
a que sí pero no es así yo creo que el
hecho de que guinea ecuatorial sea el
único país también puede ser un más para
el sistema para el sistema africana en
particular porque nos permite recibir
países de américa del sur nos permite
también que otras personas que viven en
áfrica que nunca van a tener la
oportunidad de venir saca nada o deben
irse simplemente al países donde se
hable español van a poder descubrir otra
cultura porque en guinea ecuatorial se
come como como en cuba de hecho en cuba
están muchos de cuatro kenianos que se
van allá para estudiar para ser médico
este es como la parte positiva
bueno favorita no sé pero al que a mí
más me gusta y se llama módica salsa de
módica y sin ingredientes tiene ese
plato
mucho picante éste se pone algún
ingrediente que se llama chocolate pero
no es chocolate que se pone la tarta y
este también el pescado pero un pescado
típico y nosotros hacemos plátano
machacado también ustedes lo hacen es
servir el plátano luego machacar a
analizar un poco de aceite y luego como
motivo por una próxima nota mariana que
nos va a preparar en vivo y en directo
plato típicas de canadá ecuatorial y
salsa de módica ahora volviendo al tema
de la lengua
perdón mariana no es el español la única
lengua hablada en el cálculo ecuatorial
también hablan francés mucho más
los estudiantes ahí viajan se van a
venir que no está lejos se van a otros
países y aprenden el francés pero la
mayoría más del 80% es el español y la
otra cosa también es que el acento de
los ecuatoguineanos es más un acento me
extraña porque los españoles fueron los
que colonizaron a veces a gente que me
dice pero tú no tiene acento porque yo
en canadá claro y tengo amigos mexicanos
cubanos dominicanos cuando tienes
variedades de
de países distintos acentos pues es
difícil
identificarse a uno y el francés lo
aprendí cerca entonces ya venía hablando
francés desde desde tu país en línea
ecuatorial
hay una bueno en malabo que es la ciudad
principal tenemos una escuela francesa
diez más
es un sistema tú vas a la escuela pero
los profesores viven a francia en
situación los exámenes y ellos te hacen
la corrección así que yo no tuve que
llegar a canadá para aprender el francés
y lo aprendí al portugués también se
habla portugués pero muy
los que descubrieron la isla justamente
fueron los portugueses y la isla antes
no se llamaba maría isabel no se llama
alguien ecuatorial como se llama hoy y
lo que hay que saber que hay tres países
en áfrica que se llaman guinea claro yo
nací en una la línea francesa y crecí en
otra que está alineada a español ahora
esas tres lenguas que tú nombras que
vinieron desde afuera y las lenguas
nativas de lenguas nativas ha sido claro
áfrica tiene más de cinco tenemos éste
el funk que es el
la principal que tenemos los bubis que
vienen después tenemos
otras ahora otras pequeñas lenguas pero
estas son las que yo podría más a poner
adelante si las hablas hablas de algunas
de esas lenguas
bueno hablar para tener una conversación
como la estoy teniendo no pero si es que
una persona me conversa en tango yo
puedo responder en español o decir
algunas cositas como anv o lan significa
hola aquí va desgracias
para ir cerrando esta conversación
porque el tiempo se va mucho más rápido
de lo que uno supone cuando se está en
radio
las relaciones que ustedes se han
establecido aquí en canadá pertenecen
más a la comunidad general global
diversa de la que hemos estado hablando
durante estos 45 minutos o pertenecen a
la comunidad negra en particular pues
constituyó diversa
si yo enseño y entonces tengo alumnas de
diversas comunidades que hemos hecho
buenas relaciones mis amigos también
comunidad diversa
tengo amigos negros tengo amigos blancos
tengo amigos mestizos
diversas en mi caso no
del mes de la negritud y los que
organizan hnos las activo
no sólo son africanos todo ahí este que
vemos que organizan porque hay que saber
que el hecho de que existe el mes de la
negritud es para
hacer saber a otras personas que existe
una historia que a lo mejor no se va a
encontrar en una biblioteca o en un
manual y las personas que participan a
estas actividades no sólo son personas
que vienen de la comunidad negra vienen
otras personas con mucha más curiosidad
y cuando con ella habla del arte pues
cuando estás en un mundo artístico ya
que me otra parte también soy artista
este son variedades de culturas no te
queda de otra que de colaborar con
personas de diversas sonidos y el señor
pasar bueno después de 50 años de vivir
aquí 5 y 2 52 años llegamos crisis ya
uno no sabe si preguntarle si considera
esta sociedad adoptiva o ya pasó a ser
la adoptiva o la más lejana en todo caso
de la sociedad de haití que se considera
se considera una un haitiano se
considera una que ve com
y cada día en un evento diciendo
que estoy un negro
pero lo que yo sé son un hombre
que necesita que quiere el aspecto de
toda la gente
así estoy pero claro que tengo amigos de
todas las comunidades puesto algún
hombre más que tú
en un hombre muy fuerte
bueno entonces antes de cerrar nuestro
encuentro nos quedan muy pocos minutos
no sé palos y vos tenés a mano el tema
que has trabajado esta semana que
quieras comentarle a la audiencia bueno
sí muy rápidamente no fue una entrevista
que hice con un artista visual
colombiana que vive en toronto ella se
llama claudia arana y en el marco de
este mes de la negritud de la historia
de la negritud en canadá se organizó en
la ciudad de toronto una exposición de
dos artistas de dos artistas uno es
de kenia creo y la otra artista ella es
de origen jamaiquino entonces pues se
organizó una exposición de las obras de
estas personas esa exposición se llama
caminos convergentes o converge en
passeig en inglés y dura hasta el mes
hasta finales del mes de febrero
entonces pues simplemente decir que sí
que algunos que nos están escuchando y
viven en toronto y desean pasar a
visitar esta exposición lo pueden hacer
y si no pues pueden escuchar la
entrevista con esta esta colombiana que
es la curadora de esa exposición y bueno
pues eso lo visitando nuestro sitio
internet perfecto ese es uno de los
temas entonces que hemos trabajado a lo
largo de esta semana por mi parte los
invito
a leer el contenido y escuchar el
contenido de una entrevista que le hice
a gustavo zamora jiménez que es del
círculo de las primeras naciones de la
universidad de quebec aquí en montreal y
allí en el círculo están preparando unas
jornadas para el mes de abril sobre el
tema de apropiación enseñanza y
traducción de las lenguas indígenas como
ustedes saben 2019 es el año anunciado
por naciones unidas como el año
internacional de las lenguas indígenas
que están en peligro de extinción no
tenemos absolutamente ya más tiempo
agradecemos la presencia de nuestros
invitados gabriel bazán mariana valdez y
ana espinoza muchas gracias por estar
aquí muchas gracias a todos los que nos
siguen a través de los diversos medios
por los que nos siguen cada semana
facebook live youtube nuestro sitio en
internet www rc y net punto sea espero
que les haya gustado esta experiencia de
estar con nosotros fuera de espacio
radial del estudio radial que ocupamos
cada
cada semana y ya tienen entonces
esta nueva este nuevo homenaje a la
comunidad negra de aquí de canadá saben
que existe cada mes de febrero de cada
año y que existe en nuestro sitio
internet donde pueden encontrar todo
nuestro contenido les agradecemos a
todos ya simplemente de dejarles la
última palabra a nuestros invitados y
cortistas muy rápidamente
algo que como encantado de estar acá con
ustedes muchísimas gracias
yo recuerdo la colectividad
activa
y de la invitación vive el amor y la paz
gracias a ustedes por estar aquí muchas
gracias mi querido colega y amigo pablo
gómez barrios de esta mesa y los
invitamos a encontrarse con nosotros
nuevamente la próxima semana
aquí en nuestro espacio de el castor
mensajero o como lo llamamos
oficialmente de hace un tiempo
canadá en las américas café muchas
gracias chau hasta la próxima
[Música]